WELCOME EVERYONE TO OUR.
HEARING OF THE.
ASSEMBLY NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE OF MAY SEVENTH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN.
MCCARTY OR HERE TO PRESENT AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY NINE. THIS DOES
ENJOY A.
SUPPORT SUPPORT RECOMMENDATION
YES
YOU.
SHARE.
RIGHT HERE AND.
MEMBER.
ISN'T THAT DISTRICT HEALTH. AND
TAKE YOU FOR WORKING WITH
WITHOUT THE LAST FEW WEEKS.
TO MAKE SURE WE GOT THE SOME
PLACES YOU PLAY TO RIGHT
DOWNTOWN REALLY AREN'T YOU MAY
NOTICE A FEW.
BOXES HERE IS THE LARGEST
BUILDING VALUE WEST OF THE
MISSISSIPPI. VIOLENT EVER HERE
AND THIS WILL ALLOW US TO TO GET
THE PROJECT GOING.
PLEASE EXCUSE INTERESTING LANDS
COMMISSION THIS
SACRAMENTO.
TRANSFERRING.
THE LAND BACK TO THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO. RIVER HE SLIPPED
THROUGH HER THAT REALLY ARE.
IS IT SAFE TO STOP.
FOCUSED ON SUNDAY CLOUDED AT
TITLE OVER THE YEARS IT GETS US
GOING IN.
THIS IS.
SACRAMENTO REPRESENTATIVE.
RIGHT.
YEAH. HUNDRED THE.
LEGISLATION TO GRANT THE LAND
THAT THE STATE ACQUIRED BACK TO
THE
CITY TO HOLD IN TRUST AND SO
THAT'S WHAT THIS LEGISLATION
DOES.
AND WE WOULD RECOMMEND YOUR AYE
VOTE AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU I'M SURE PATTERSON FOR
THE CITY SACRAMENTO WE'RE CO
SPONSORED THE BILL WE APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NARRATOR WE APPEARS TO HAVE A
QUORUM A MADAM SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
MEMBERS MERIT SEARCHING HERE
MURATSUCHI HERE ACOSTA. HERE
PASSING HERE CHAU CHOW HERE
EGGMAN FLORA.
FLORA HERE LIMON.
LIMON HERE MCCARTY HERE MCCARTY
HERE. MELENDEZ
STONE.
ALRIGHT.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES FOR THE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
SPELL PLEASE COME FORWARD.
SEEING NONE DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
COME FORWARD SEEING NONE DO WE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
BUT.
OKAY.
MR MCCARTY OR YOU. ARE
ACCEPTING GO ALL AMENDMENTS
CORRECT THANK YOU THANK YOU
MOTION'S BEEN MADE AND SECONDED.
CHAIRS RECOMMENDATION IS AND I.
DISCOVERY.
I AM ONE AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY NINE
BY MEMBER MCCARTY MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS MURATSUCHI AYE ROUTES
RICHIE I ACOSTA BY ACOSTA AYE
CHAU. CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
FLORA.
I LIMON. LIMON AYE MCCARTY AYE
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ.
STONE.
SEVEN ZERO THE BILL'S OUT THANK
YOU.
NEXT WE HAVE.
MISTER BLOOM WITH A. B. TWENTY
SEVEN NINETY SEVEN.
THIS BILL ALSO ENJOYS HIS
SUPPORT SUPPORT RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD
AFTERNOON TO ALL OF YOU A RECENT
COURT CASE
CAL NO GARDENS VERSUS CITY OF
LOS ANGELES. HAS UNDERMINED THE
APPLICATION OF MELLOW AND
DENSITY BONUS LAW IN THE COASTAL
ZONE. IN THAT CASE A DEVELOPER
PROPOSED A SMALL RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENT IN THE VENICE AREA
OF LOS ANGELES THAT INCLUDED
AFFORDABLE UNITS IN COMPLIANCE
WITH THE MELLOW ACT.
AND A DENSITY BONUS UNDER STATE
LAW AND ALTHOUGH THE PROJECT WAS
CONSISTENT WITH THE BOTH THE
LOCAL PLANNING AND ZONING AND
THE DENSITY BONUS LAW. THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT DENIED THE PROJECT ON
THE BASIS THAT THE INCREASED
DENSITY. MADE THE PROJECT
VISUALLY INCOMPATIBLE WITH THE
SURROUNDING NEIGHBORHOOD IN
VIOLATION OF THE COASTAL ACT.
THE APPELLATE COURT UPHELD THE
DENIAL FINDING THAT THE COASTAL
ACCENT SUPERSEDES DENSITY BONUS
LAW.
AND IF NOT CORRECTED THIS
DECISION WILL LIKELY PREVENT
DENSITY BONUS LAW FROM BEING
USED AND THE COASTAL ZONE. AND
WILL UNDERMINE THE PRESERVATION
OF PRODUCTION OF HOUSING AND THE
MELLOW ACT THE RESULT WILL BE
FEWER AFFORDABLE UNITS WITHIN
THE COASTAL ZONE. A RESULT THAT
WE CAN SCARCELY. A ALLOW IT THIS
TIME SO AB TWENTY SEVEN NINETY
SEVEN WILL CLARIFY A PARTISAN IN
THE DENSITY BONUS LAW. TO ENSURE
THAT A PROJECT COULD NOT BE
FOUND INCONSISTENT WITH THE
COASTAL ACT MERELY BECAUSE IT
RECEIVES A DENSITY INCREASE
UNDER STATE LAW.
I WANT TO POINT OUT THAT WE
WORKED OUT ALL OF OUR CONCERNS
WITH THE COASTAL COMMISSION AND
OTHER OPPOSITION. AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR HER
ARRIVAL.
IT WOULD HAVE ON THE LAWLER FROM
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND THE.
VIA A THIS WEEK OLDER BRIAN
AUGUSTA WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
VERGE ON ALL WITH THE WESTERN
TOWN ON POVERTY I APPRECIATE ALL
THE WORK THE CONSULTANT PUT INTO
HELPING US WORK THIS OUT WITH
THE COASTAL COMMISSION OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS UNDERSTAND IT'S
RARE TO HAVE A BILL IN THIS
COMMITTEE. THAT INVOLVES THE
COASTAL ACT THAT DOES NOT HAVE A
POSITION OR CONTROVERSY SO WE'RE
HAPPY TO DELIVER YOU WANT.
THIS WILL MAKE IT SO THAT
DEVELOPERS CAN CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE AFFORDABLE UNITS UNDER
THAT'S ABOUT ISLAMIC PISTOLS N
ALSO PROTECTING THE POST AND WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
BRIAN CUSTER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION FOR ALL OF THOSE
REASONS WE WOULD ASK WHEN I
ABOUT.
VERY MUCH ANY FURTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF THE BELL PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THE BAKER WITH THEIR
NEEDS IT READING ASSOCIATES FOR
THE RESOURCES LEGACY FUND.
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THAT'S
GONE INTO THESE AMENDMENTS SO WE
CAN BE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AT GOOD AFTERNOON HOW JOHNSON
CIRCLE CALIFORNIA AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA COASTAL
PROTECTION NETWORK ENVIRONMENT.
VARMINT CALIFORNIA AZUL NATURIST
AS DEFENSE COUNSEL AND SURFRIDER
IT'S IMPORTANT THINK THE AUTHOR
AND STAFF AND SPONSORS
FORGETTING TO ECONOMICS.
GOOD AFTERNOON SIR CRISTINA THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL COMMISSION
AND ALTHOUGH THE COMMISSION HAS
NOT HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE
AN OFFICIAL POSITION ON THE
AMENDED VERSION OF THIS BILL.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS
AND YOUR EXCELLENT COMMITTEE
STAFF AND THE AMENDMENTS FULLY
RESEARCH RESOLVE ALL OF OUR
CONCERNS SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MOVE THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED.
ACTUALLY MISTER CHAO'S
MOVEMENTS LIVE ON SECOND
YOUR THIRD.
AND.
FOURTH ANY FURTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAMBERS MOST AND MORE
WHICH I ORDER ENTRY ON BEHALF OF
LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI
IN SUPPORT.
AND FOR THE WITNESSES SUPPORT
AND WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN AND QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
MOST MADE AND SECONDED MISTER
BLOOM WAS LIKE CLOTHES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ARRIVAL.
VERY MUCH.
CHAIRS RECOGNITION IS AND I.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
I DON'T TO AB TWENTY SEVEN
NINETY SEVEN BY MEMBER BLOOM THE
MOTION IS TO PASS.
MEMBERS ROUTE SEARCHLIGHT
MURATSUCHI AYE ACOSTA AYE AYE
ACOSTA AYE CHAU.
CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA. FLORA AYE
LIMON.
LOW MOAN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ.
LINDA'S AYE STONE.
NINE ZERO THE BILL'S OUT THANK
YOU.
ALRIGHT ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO ADD
ON.
OKAY.
YEAH.
WHICH IS CALLED THE BILL.
ITEM ONE A. B. SEVENTEEN FIFTY
NINE BY MCCARTY DO PASS AS
AMENDED REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. CURRENT VOTE SIX TO
ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE MELENDEZ LINDA'S I.
STONE AND NO NO. NO OKAY THE
LOOKING.
.
JUST WAIT AND SEE A NEED FOR
SUCH A MEMBER. YEAH NOTICES
COULD ARGUE POSITION YEAH.
BONTA CHIU ANYBODY FROM
PRESENTED RIGHT NOW.
HERE SHORTLY.
YOU HAVE SOMETHING THAT'S THE.
IS TECHNICALLY SPEAKING IS A
CHAIR NEED TO BE HERE.
TO DO THAT ON THOSE BELIEFS.
JERRY YEAH JUST WONDERING. HOW
YOU KNOW ABOUT HIM IS THE GAP
OF?
YEAH.
ZERO CLICK IT OR. NOT GOT SICK.
SO WHEN HIS OR
AND REPEAT THAT.
OKAY RECORDS VOTE YEAH CURRENT
VOTE IS A TWO ZERO NAVY
SEVENTEEN FIFTY NINE ABSENT
MEMBER MARK STONE. STONE AYE
NINE ZERO.
I DON'T TO AB TWENTY SEVEN%
NINETY SEVEN BY BLOOM TO PASS
CURRENT VOTE EIGHT ZERO ABSENT
MEMBERS STONE BY. STONE AYE NINE
ZERO.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS
MEETING IS ADJOURNED